hey what's up guys it's mkbhd and you
know what i like i like phones and you
know what else i like i like computers
i'm sure we probably share some of that
in common well i had this pretty
interesting thought a couple weeks ago
and i shared it on google plus which is
down in the description and i thought
you guys on youtube might like to hear a
bit of it too so what if phones were a
lot more like desktop computers maybe
not macs but desktop computers that you
can completely personalize down to the
spec you can build it from scratch now i
know not everyone would want this but
think of the possibilities for example
let's say you really like the iphone 4
but then there's just something about uh
the antenna that you don't like so you
want to get the iphone 4 but move the
antenna a little bit up
you can do that or say you've been
holding back from buying the samsung
galaxy s2 because the screen isn't a
high enough resolution well what if you
could get a samsung galaxy s2 and then
tell the person oh yeah but put the
retina display on that please what if
you could do that but seriously what if
you could just walk into a store like
you could walk into a computer store and
just start picking out components and
put them all together and put android on
it and have that that that would be one
of the coolest things ever so with
building a computer you start from the
chassis you pick the body you pick all
the internal components and then you
pick windows and then you put it all
together and it's your dream computer if
you could do this with a smartphone what
would i choose i would have the nexus
ones outside with the galaxy s2 screen
and it would be running stock android
not the touchwiz interface that's and
i'd also have a 1.5 gigahertz processor
in there instead of the 1.2 gigahertz
one gig of ram i just load up on all the
specs and go for the max and pay
whatever i have to pay for that so if
you could pick the specs for your phone
like let me know down in the description
what would you pick would you just go
with the stock iphone you know whatever
they put on the shelf you just buy it
because that's kind of like the
all-in-ones that you're getting on in
computers right now or would you
actually go through step by step and
pick each the operating system the
hardware the software the ram the
processor things like that i have a
feeling a lot of you guys might do the
same as me and put android on it but a
lot of the people who already use
iphones are totally fine with that and
would rather just keep the iphone so
i've given you my dream phone specs and
if you think this is a pretty cool idea
give this video a thumbs up and let me
know what would you put in your phone